back in my edgy ntsgw gamer bro days i
used to believe in something called the
meritocracy meaning that in modern
society everyone is rewarded according
to their merits and not superficial
characteristics such as gender or skin
color for example i studied for my end
of high school exams got a decent score
and got accepted into a good university
not because i'm white not because i'm
male but because i worked hard that's
how it goes you just gotta stop being
lazy and start studying all those
pink-haired sjw types in the us are
crazy to demand admission based on
gender or skin color i thought they just
need to put in the work instead of
trying to guilt-strip polite society
into giving them a pass i thought we
live in a meritocracy i thought and i
was wrong the system we mean by
meritocracy does not exist let me
explain the whole point of anitocracy
once again is that only your performance
counts how well you can do a thing
determines your reward as opposed to
innate characteristics such as skin
color or ethnicity which should be
irrelevant so what would be a good
example for a working meritocracy online
video games right where the only thing
that matters is how well you can aim how
fast you can shoot and so on all players
are hidden behind freely chosen
usernames so things like sex and race
don't play a role online gaming is a
true meritocracy or so i thought and i
was once again wrong let's take a game
like world of tanks as an example which
i used to play a lot and no this is not
an ad segment everyone starts out with
the same tanks and it's up to you to do
online battles with those tanks with
other players usually in a 15 vs 15
format where you get credits and
experience based on your battle
performance which you can then use to
either upgrade your tank or get new more
powerful tanks this should be a true
meritocracy in any sense of the word but
it isn't why is that first off not
everyone has the same computer what if
you have low grade hardware and you can
only play at 15 frames per second and
that causes you to miss a critical shot
and get killed someone playing at 200
fps with an rtx 390 ti will have an
inherent advantage over you the reward
system doesn't account for this or what
if you have a bad internet connection
that keeps lagging constantly causing
you to once again miss shots and get
killed someone with gigabit fiber optics
has a significant advantage over you at
that point but the reward system doesn't
account for this either and if you're a
teenager or young adult what if you have
to share one room with three of your
siblings who keep noising around behind
your back making it harder to
concentrate someone who has their own
private room is not affected by this
handicap or as a world of tanks classic
what if your opponent is using premium
ammo and a premium tank superior to
regular ammo and tanks that premium t26
e5 will delete your regular vk45 in one
on one and there is nothing you can do
about it so what's the solution here
well just get better hardware get a
better internet connection get your own
room to play in and get premium ammo and
tanks easy right just go and buy all
that and the odds will be evened and
this is all well and good as long as you
have the money if you can't afford good
hardware broadband internet your own
private room and premium subscription
you are at a significant disadvantage or
in case you're underage if your parents
can't afford these things and sometimes
it's not even a question of money what
if you live in an area where a fast
internet isn't available and you're
stuck with a slow laggy connection that
means your battle performance is
determined more by your postal code than
your individual skill and willingness to
get better so as we can see while in
online games your individual skill
definitely counts wealth is just as
important of a factor so to go back to
my initial example i studied for my end
of high school exams got a decent score
and got accepted into a good university
how was i able to do that was it because
i worked hard and wasn't lazy to some
extent sure i worked hard and wasn't
lazy in my own private room based on
instructions by good teachers using high
quality textbooks with supportive
parents after years of professional help
during my childhood to eliminate my
learning disabilities while eating
healthy nutritious meals in a house with
electricity and running water compare
this to say a roma teenager living in
eastern hungary at the age of town in
deep poverty who really wants to get
into university like i did they study
hard in a crowded room based on
instructions by overworked unmotivated
teachers using substandard out of date
textbooks with unsupported parents with
learning disabilities that were never
corrected while eating cheap low-quality
meals in a house with barely electricity
and possibly no running water so suppose
both the roma teenager and i achieved
the same score on the end of high school
exam so the million dollar question is
did the two of us have to work just as
hard to achieve the same score like in a
true meritocracy
no absolutely not the roma teenager had
to work much much harder by an order of
magnitude that's because they had to
compensate for the substandard
circumstances they were born in and
those can only be eliminated with one
thing
wealth wealth is the cheat code to life
do we recall the 2019 college admissions
bribery scandal where it turned out that
a bunch of rich people celebrities ceos
and so on have been paying large sums of
money to get their kids into top
universities that's not too much talker
tech or let's take amazon their average
employee made twenty nine thousand seven
dollars in 2020 while jeff bezos made 70
billion dollars now do you think jeff
bezos worked 2 million for 13 210.6
times harder than the average employee
to earn that money
yeah right we don't live in meritocracy
we never did and will not for quite some
time and the people who insist allowed
us that we do or either rich [ __ ]
who benefit from the current system the
most or simply dupes who bought into the
whole pull yourself up by your own
bootstraps scam so how do we achieve
meritocracy or at least something close
to it simple by smoothing over the
disadvantages affecting people as much
as possible that means free school meals
social housing programs food vouchers
that can be redeemed for healthy food at
stores affordable public transportation
making internet access a public utility
after-school programs for children from
poor backgrounds and higher taxes on
people like jeff bezos and elon musk
also let's invest in historically poor
neighborhoods to bring them up to par
and take into account a person's
socio-economic background during things
like college admission and don't believe
those on tv who tell you that true
meritocracy is when everyone is on their
own without any state support those
people are millionaires funded by
billionaires as the letter profit most
from the current system they get
billions of extra profits yachts
hollywood villas and manhattan luxury
apartments while the rest of us get
rising energy prices inflation
unaffordable housing and dysfunctional
hollowed-out public services and if you
dare to criticize this state of school
they'll call you communist cultural
marxist sjw whatever phrase they can use
to rile up their political base this
season don't fall for their manipulation
if you like meritocracy if you think we
should aspire towards it you should
support pro-human western european style
social policies the alternative is just
more zeros in jeff piso's bank account
and less zeros in yours thank you for
watching don't forget to like and
subscribe and i do have a patreon as
well if you think this content is worth
your money and i'll be seeing you next
time